[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello good people of the internet Dave
Rubin in the Rubin Reports studio we're
testing some stuff today just tightening
up some nuts and bolts around here we
are live streaming right now on the
YouTube and on the Facebook at the exact
same time you might be watching this on
YouTube comm slash Rubin report you
might be watching this on facebook.com
slash David you might be watching this
on facebook.com slash Rubin report any
of those options are possible the choice
is yours
we've been taping a bunch of stuff today
we just retake a new channel trailer
that'll be out soon I had a great
interview this morning with Jason
Whitlock who a lot of you guys have
asked me to have on he's from Fox Sports
one
really outspoken guy who's in the sports
world but really is focused on how it's
connected often in a pretty terrible way
actually with the politics world and how
these things get meshed together and we
had a great discussion about political
correctness and free speech and money in
politics and money in sports and the
business side of the whole thing it was
it was a true pleasure and it's always
great to sit down with someone that at
the end of the hour I'm like wow there's
another ally in this space and I think I
think you'll find that Jason absolutely
is an ally that'll be up tomorrow so
what we're gonna do or do a little ask
me anything as we're testing out some
equipment here today so you can ask me
anything we'll give preferential
treatment to you people on super chat
I'm sure most of you guys know how that
works but if you throw in a couple bucks
your your chat gets bumped up because
the YouTube live chat obviously is
usually totally bananas god bless all
yeah and you throw in a couple bucks
your chat gets bumped up David Namira
can see it they send it to my trusty
iPad over here and it's quite a
technological thing we got going over
here and and then we'll answer some
questions I'll also take some questions
from if you're in the patreon feed right
now if you're in the Facebook feed we'll
take a gander at that it's a little
harder to check on on YouTube and I
don't know if anyone's monitoring
Twitter but where the questions come
I'll just start answering them so yeah
as I said Jason Whitlock on tomorrow the
reaction to the Bret Weinstein chat that
we had last week was absolutely off the
charts and I'm proud to say that between
what we did with Bret and then
a couple days later he was on Joe Rogan
it really did amplify this story I saw
there was a link to a story about what's
happening at Evergreen State over on
Drudge today so things are moving on
that it's an important story of truly
what I've been talking about for a long
time that the left will come to eat
their own this is a movement based on
destruction so Bret is a leftist he's a
bernie voting progressive who just
slightly veered out of the lane that
they allow him to be in he was actually
fighting against segregation he was
fighting against racism against looking
at someone's skin color and saying
whether they can be on campus or not and
now the campus has been closed for three
days their kids are carrying bats around
they're breaking windows swastikas I
mean crazy nonsense and of course this
is mainly being ignored by the
mainstream media as I said Drudge
touched it but that's not mainstream and
and the left isn't touching it at all
because they don't want to touch it
because then it will reflect right back
on them because these ideas of screaming
racist bigoted homophobic everybody are
the things that they've pushed for so
long so I'm happy that it's moving
forward my direct message tomorrow is a
little bit about that it's a little bit
about this Bill Maher n-word situation a
little bit about Kathy Griffin and the
decapitated Trump thing from last week
and you know all these things that we're
talking about have consistently just
stayed in the news all right let's get
to some questions from Facebook does
pineapple go on Pizza pineapple does not
go on pizza I stand firmly for that
super chat what are your thoughts on the
up and coming March against Sharia it
seems they are trying to twist our
protection of women so I know that this
march against Sharia is coming I think
maybe this has a little something to do
with my former guest Brigitte Gabriel
which may have been the single best
reaction we've ever got to an interview
and if you watch the whole thing watch
her speech at the end the last five
minutes are some of the best five
minutes we've ever done here I mean
although I said that something flew in
my eye or the lights got in my I mean
she actually started bringing tears out
in me because it's such a beautiful
speech about what freedom really is and
why you have to fight for a generation
after generation so as for the march
against Sharia of course I don't want to
be too controversial here folks
but we should not have Sharia law in the
United States I know even if you say
that it somehow makes you seem like
you're a power
right-wing lunatic but there are the
underpinnings and again this is a lot
coming from this alliance between the
left and Islamism that would lead people
to believe in this so enough people are
going we have to march against this what
we should be marching for is liberalism
and logic and reason because these are
the antidotes not only to Sharia but to
any bad idea whatever authoritarian bad
idea you don't like whether it's the far
left progressive ideology or whether
it's some far-right authoritarian
ideology the answer to all of that is
more freedom is more Liberty
that's why whether you say you're a
classical liberal or libertarian or
whatever whatever you you know the words
are becoming less meaningful in a
certain respect but whatever you say you
are if your basis is intended
individuality and in Liberty then we got
something to talk about so I what I'm
going to try to do with the show and
what I've tried but I definitely want to
double down more is talking about the
things that I really do believe in and
not just waiting for some bad [ __ ] to
happen and then having to react to it so
as for the March I think having a March
to show people that we're against Sharia
well okay that that should be understood
on face value but what do we actually
stand for what is better than that and I
would argue that that's Liberty from
super chat is the interview between you
and Lacey happening it is happening 100%
it looks like the end of June we're just
trying to work out the date I just heard
today speaking of dates I heard that
she's dating a youtuber and friend of
the show and friend of mine Chris Raygun
so I just invited them over for dinner
and well we'll see about that but
Lacey's going through a really really
interesting thing this is not someone I
was tremendously familiar with about a
year ago but she was big on the SJW side
of things did a lot of videos on that
she's had her awakening her red pilling
as you kids say and and even today she
was talking about how friends are
turning on her I can see a lot of the
left people on Twitter attacking her
mercilessly you know I know that I lost
a lot of friends even just this week to
people to people who I've worked with in
the past on this show and some other
things legit verified public people I
notice unfollowed me on Twitter to
people that I was sort of on the fence
with I could tell they weren't too
thrilled with me you know bigoted racist
white supremacist homophobe over here
and and I just saw that they dropped too
so it's an ongoing
that all of us I think that are in this
space that somehow say no I'm going I've
lived one way I've thought one way but
I'm going to now think differently we
all go through this thing but you know
what as I said to Lacey on Twitter just
an hour ago
it's like if you are going to lose
friends over politics and because
they've seen your evolution well you got
to really judge what that friendship was
and while I I don't want to say regret I
have a fondness for some people from a
long time ago that won't talk to me
anymore
I've actually made some really really
great friends in the past year in this
space I mean a guy like Colin Moriarty
has become one of my best friends didn't
know the guy six months ago Eric
Weinstein Brett Weinstein I got all the
wine Stein's
and several other people by opening
myself up to the ideas that I truly
believe in you will find more people
coming to you so I know many of you guys
struggle with this this idea that if you
start saying what you think your friends
are going to defriend you and all that
stuff you will find other friends and
you can find them in all sorts of places
whether it's in the comments section
here and then you end up in real life
being friends with somebody or just just
telling somebody that you meet at a bar
what you really think and and it's
usually okay alright let's jump over to
patreon do you think that we the
Liberals are actually winning the
culture war or have we just had of you a
few of prominent victories in a long war
I've been thinking a lot about this is
this is a great question so I think
suddenly we've had a couple bursts of
win some you know an influential person
like lacy on YouTube who has such a
great young audience coming out for for
the liberal side of things and getting
out of that I think that's a nice win I
think what's happening at Evergreen is a
win for us in that it is so absurd Bret
is not racist he is a far Lefty Bernie
voting progressive not racist okay
loves all of those ideas biology
professor okay these things are becoming
so obvious that we are getting a couple
wins what happened to Colin when when
the International Business Times called
him racist even though his tweet had
nothing to do with race and then we
expose that and then he gets on Rogan
Bret gets on Rogan they come here
there's enough of us starting to align
together that I do feel like there's a
little bit of
a there's a shift that I suspect
mainstream will eventually pick up on
and co-opt which will kind of suck I
don't think we're winning in that the
ideas of leftism this regressive sjw
oppression Olympics all this stuff it is
so ingrained and so big actually watch
the beginning of my interview with Jason
tomorrow where we talk about this where
these people that are relentlessly
fighting Trump and the resistance they
think they're fighting the power but I
personally I agree with what Jason said
it's not Trump that really is the power
if you think about who controls the
media and who controls Hollywood and all
of these ideas that we hear all the time
that's really not Trump in a way he's
taking or hatchet to it now you may not
like Trump of all those reasons again I
did not vote for Trump I actually voted
for Gary Johnson I did videos on why not
to vote for Trump I warned that if a if
liberalism doesn't take root that
someone like Trump will rise at the same
time I'm actually fine that Trump won I
think that this is put the chessboard up
and the pieces are all over the place
and everyone's kind of reevaluating
their things so I am okay with that at
the moment I don't think he is a Russian
agent if eventually the evidence comes
through that he is well we'll deal with
that at the time but I think we've had a
couple nice wins here but we've got to
keep standing for him and show people
we're actually here we're not if look if
you're basing your stuff on logic and
reason and trying to really find answers
and not basing on hate or on xenophobia
or any of that stuff it's a little
harder to gin people up right so it's a
little harder for us to do it but I
think we have our work cut out for us
and I think I think a lot of us are up
to the challenge and I and I'm
incredibly enthused by that all right
let's see why do you believe the left
says the right wants to make people poor
lower taxes and smaller governments seem
like something that would benefit us all
that's a super chat so you know I've
shift most of my views I think if you
were to ask me in 1990 when I was sort
of first get into politics first couple
years in eighth grade or something and I
considered myself liberal most of my
views are pretty much the same from back
then I've shifted a little bit on
certain economic stuff and I do see that
the tax stuff to me now is something
that I do I guess I've shifted a little
right on
you should keep as much of your money as
you've earned now I understand we have
to have some social safety net we got to
have roads and things I've had
anarcho-capitalist on here like Brian
Kaplan who would say privatize
everything I'm certainly not for that
that's sort of the difference we're
we're a classical liberal and a
libertarian
see that that split because there's a
lot of commonality there because it's
based in Liberty and individualism and I
love that but it's hard to defined as a
libertarian say there should be no
government that's more the
anarcho-capitalist side a classical
liberal says there's some utility for
government I think that's a great
conversation that we should all have but
I agree with the premise of your
question here which is let's you
whatever you watching this whatever you
earn I want you to keep as much of that
as possible now if you're worried that
well then we're not going to fund the
Arts or fund Planned Parenthood or fund
several whatever else it is well then
you'll have more money you'll have more
money at your discretion to do whatever
you want to hopefully use it for a park
in your community or whatever else you
think I believe if you give people back
the power that the people will do more
responsible things that they care about
more hopefully within their own
communities so I think that part of the
reason that people think the right the
scary right hates the poor is just
because it goes to what I just said a
few minutes ago about the left sort of
controls the media narrative the
Hollywood narrative the comedy narrative
all those things now I think that's kind
of breaking these days and I think
that's that's pretty damn good
one more on super chat then I'll jump
over to Facebook thanks for doing what
you do Dave people like you or why our
civilization will survive wishing you
well from Canada well thank you for that
people like me or white civilization
civilizations in a lot of trouble I'm
doing the best I can but you've got some
great people up there like Jordan
Peterson and GAD said and by the way you
know when we our fan funded on patreon
as you guys know and one of the rewards
that we do depending on how much you
give I do these private chats with
people once a month or we do some small
group chats Google Hangouts with people
and I've gotten to know a ton of people
and it's really cool and I've watched
people get to know each other all over
the world but we have a
disproportionately high amount of people
in Canada that are part of that I think
I've asked them well why do you think
that is and several people who said well
Canada were so polite over here but
nobody wants to offend anybody so we
don't really talk about these things so
they're looking for another
so I haven't been up to Canada in a
while and I really do need to get back
up there let me jump over to patreon
what are you most looking forward to
next week at oak on would you have your
own Brooke on again to talk religion
versus morality immigration and how to
end terrorism once and for all so I am
going to be in Pittsburgh for a couple
days a token which is the ein Rand
conference that they do every year I'm
going to be doing a panel with Steve
Simpson who have done some traveling
with and Fleming Rose who was on the
show who is the editor of the Danish
magazine the printed the Mohammed
cartoons he's become a stalwart defender
of free speech he's a great great guy
who I'm proud to call a friend now and
we're gonna be doing a panel on free
speech your own we just rebooked them
actually yesterday it's I think it's the
first week in August he will be back on
he's a great clear thinker but by the
way I'll tell you something about your
own I think I've mentioned this once or
twice it was a year ago this week June
13th so I guess technically next week
that we went independent on patreon and
you know we had a cushy job at aura TV
it was great and Larry King was
wonderful to have welcomed me in there
and thought that I could be a decent
interviewer and all that and it was this
week that we were just preparing to
leave and I said to David and Amira
let's give up our salaries let's give up
our health insurance let's try to do
this patreon thing which is huge now but
nobody really knew what it was at the
time and it a lot of it had to do with a
conversation that I had had about two
weeks before and you can watch the
interview watch my interview with your
own talking about rational self-interest
talking about doing things for yourself
so that you can do good for others
and I really do like a lot of those
ideas and I've tried to put them in play
not only in my personal life but in my
professional life now that I have a
small business here and how I operate
with professionally and all those things
so yes your own will be back on and I'm
looking most forward I guess to my to my
little talk but it'll be nice to meet
some interesting people when I've done
some of these tours that I've done with
Faizal and with Colin and with Michael
Shermer and Christina that have all been
through a RI we've met ton of great kids
and with real diversity you know the
diversity I like it's not just the
diversity of color I like the diversity
of thought okay let's see Facebook who
is your favorite youtuber
uh who's my favorite youtuber well
specific YouTube I mean Phil DeFranco is
doing great stuff and we're gonna get
him in here at some point I think he's
really really trying to analyze things
honestly and properly and he also like
me is fully independent which allows him
to do what he thinks is right and I just
I dig what he's doing and he's one of
you know people always ask though who do
you trust who do you trust he's one of
the people that I basically trust and
yeah there you go another one from
Facebook real quick what is your take on
the Qatar crisis so I think this is
extremely interesting I'm glad you asked
and I want to get somebody that's really
well versed in this to discuss I think
there's actually something good
happening here Qatar has been funding a
lot of the Terrorism throughout the
world from from from Hamas and Hezbollah
to what they're doing with the Muslim
Brotherhood that's directly connected to
the Islamist ideas that seep into the
West that these aren't jihadis meaning
they're not necessarily blowing things
up but they're trying to under they're
trying to ruin the underpinnings of
Western civilization using our systems
against us I mean watch my interview
with Brigitte Gabriel for more on that
so I think there's something interesting
that started with with Trump in Saudi
Arabia where he subtly called that out
and now suddenly all those countries are
turning against Qatar saying you're
going to shut off the spigot of money to
terrorism and al Jazeera and all this
propaganda all that now that said Saudi
Arabia does a ton of bad stuff not only
to their women and their gaze and and
their few minorities that are there but
exporting all this Wahhabi ism and all
that so there's so one thing at a time
and those are separate things but I
think basically basically something good
is coming out of that hey Dave this is
super chat hey Dave I'm a member of
Students for liberty among a number of
other organizations who would we contact
you to bring you to speak at our school
well I spoke at at University of
Maryland just a couple weeks ago with
Fleming actually and Faizal and a couple
other people for students for Liberty I
think it's a great organization I had a
great time went out with a bunch of the
kids after who would you contact go to
Rubin report comm slash contact submit
something there and we forward
everything over to my agent
so that's Rubin report comm slash
contact let's see a super chat how do
you
justify an economic safety net knowing
that evidence suggests it traps people
in poverty and slows down the economy
okay so this is another good question
that that really I need to dive into it
a different way I believe that you
should have some social safety net for
the first sort of the greater good of
society so for the people that
absolutely need it the most
that there is that that we're not just
pushing people out on the street now
there's a great argument to be made
usually by libertarians that if you took
that away that private charities private
people wealthy people organizations
religious institutions and things would
step in and do it more effectively than
having the government do that and I
think that's a really interesting
conversation to have and there's a lot
of pieces of me that that fall in that
line but I think one thing at a time and
I think for the people that need it most
you've got to have something this is
where I just think you have to have
something but you do make a good point
which is that sometimes when you have
this stuff in a certain way it locks
people in it if you if you give them
subsidized housing and you give them
money and food stamps and all those
things I'm not blaming them in any way
for their situation because there's a
million socio-economic factors and
sometimes actual racial factors and
history and historical stuff that have
led to this but at some point if you're
being given a certain amount of things
it actually becomes against your own
interest to get out of that situation
because you might have to move somewhere
that's much worse work much harder for
actually the same amount or or less etc
etc but I'm happy to discuss those ideas
further and I'm glad you asked ok this
is super chat thanks for making such a
refreshing show is there a line where
you find it difficult to continue
supporting or listening to people for
example I'm struggling to keep following
crowder with his climate change
misinformation so I don't know
specifically about crowd or in that a
couple people have tweeted me about it
I'm happy to discuss that further with
Crowder you know for my feelings on
climate change check out my interview
with Michael Mann from Penn State who's
one of the leading climate scientists in
the world you can also watch a really
interesting conversation I had with Alex
Epstein from the Center for industrial
progress who wrote a book that I keep
right there called the moral case for
fossil fuels a lot of people were angry
at me that I had a climate denier on I
didn't get the sense he was a climate
change
he just believes that fossil fuels are
the best current way to still bring the
most the most success and economic and
personal best to people of the planet
Earth I got a ton of hate for that I
mean a ton I still get a ton of hate for
that by the way after some of you know
this but after I did that interview with
Alex
he saw the comments section people were
angry at me and angry at him he did a
video on YouTube where he took like a
hundred comments out of YouTube and
responded to them so that tells you
something a little something about him
but as for well I can't comment on
crowder specifically but as for the line
that I draw you know there have been
times when I've when I've sat across
from somebody that I felt wasn't being
fully honest with me or was sort of
manipulating or not or in more cases
they're not exactly sure what they think
or sometimes you can see people sort of
lose their logic as they talk my feeling
is I you guys are smart that's really
the truth if you guys have come to this
show I believe you have some level of
intellectual curiosity and I think you
can often see what I see so you know my
policy was let the people talk and
eventually they'll wrap the noose around
them now if someone sat across from me
and was like you know what I want to
kill all the gays I want to kill all the
black people I want to kill all the
Muslims well now of court well first up
this is a studio in my home and I would
not want them in my home but I would I
would expose them for that I don't think
I would assault them in the middle of
the interview but the interview would
rap and I would make my feelings clear
about what they said so I don't think
I've ever had anyone on the show that
has crossed a line that I thought was
uncross alive had disagreements with
people but you got to remember as an
interviewer I I have to bring in all
kinds of people here just today by the
way I sent out a list of progressives
that I'd be happy to have on the show
and if I if you know I don't get
offended easily I just don't write this
stand-up for 12 years in New York I had
people screaming drunk people throwing
bottles at me and all kinds of crazy
[ __ ] it takes a lot to get offended for
me so if someone crossed the line I
would see it but I don't think it would
change how I behave necessarily wow
there's a ton of stuff coming in here
from super chat xma so to ex-muslims of
north america announced a speaking tour
for college campuses any advice for them
well Sarah hater I think is either in
charge of that or is going to be one of
the main speakers I adore Sarah she's
become a good friend of mine and she is
leading that organization in a great way
Mohammad Saeed's over there I've met a
bunch of MUC X Muslims on some of these
tours that I'm doing I think they have a
wonderful burgeoning movement and it has
nothing to do with hating Muslim people
or anything like that
it has P it it's a movement based on
people that have said I'm gonna leave
this ideology and I'm gonna find a
different ideology that I do believe in
for more on that check out my interview
with Yasmin Muhammad which of course was
demonetized by YouTube but you know
we'll go from there
super Chad hey Dave your thoughts on the
AEI Brookings project on paid family
leave
I honestly I'm not too familiar with
that but but I appreciate the question
and you did throw in $20 on that so I
promise you I will get back to you on
that one so David or Amir if you could
note that one I will get back to that
one okay let me jump back to Facebook
for just a second don't you think that
the uproar from right-wingers about
Kathy Griffin shows them to be
hypocrites versus free speech please
watch my direct message for tomorrow
it's it's a recap of some of the strange
things that happened in the world of
free speech over the last couple days
now we obviously have the Kathy Griffin
thing we had the Bill Maher n-word thing
we had the Bret Weinstein continuing
saga at Evergreen but the Kathy one
specifically flipped the narrative in a
way and I've called out the left when
they have done it and just wait for the
video tomorrow and you will see your
answer on that one on patreon have any
of your guests made you uncomfortable
especially if they disagree with your
opinions the only time that I was
actually uncomfortable was when the
first time I had Larry elder on which
I've mentioned I think is probably the
most teachable moment ever on this show
and there was a discussion when I was at
or at the time about editing it out
because I talked him about systemic
racism and he just bludgeoned me with
facts it was before Larry and I knew
each other personally and I think he was
coming in ready for a fight and I I came
into a gunfight with a with a you know
rubber hose
and and he bludgeoned me with some facts
and is not my best moment if you watch
it but in another way it is a great
moment because I took the hit and it did
change some of my thinking so that's my
first interview with Larry elder we've
by the way since become friends he's
back on the show a couple months ago and
he'll be back on again soon enough so
it's an interesting one to check out
because you can you can really see me
crumble under my own not being armed
enough for a particular conversation and
by the way I don't mind that you guys
saw me that way I don't I'm a human we
can you know like most of these
interviews we don't era live we can edit
things out there's been a couple other
times where I've dropped the ball on
this or that and we don't I don't mind
that you don't see that that you see
that I'm that I'm not perfect what a
silly thing hi Dave love YouTube week
how about having a podcast week that's
actually a great idea and speaking of
podcast I'm glad you brought that up so
as of today we are monetizing our audio
podcast so it's Rueben report on iTunes
or you can go to Reuben report comm
slash podcast you can find it anywhere
and we are monetizing through that
because you know we've taken a massive
hit here on YouTube I don't want to get
into all that right now but our Rebbe
did go way down here about 65% month
over two months all right it is what it
is but we want to make up some of that
money so that we're not so reliant on
patreon because any business should have
various channels of money the the
podcast network that we signed with they
have 100% no control over content we
100% can pick the advertisers that we're
going to work with it's a very nice
simple relationship
so zip recruiter is our first advertiser
on there which went in today zip
recruiter comms left Reuben if you want
to hook us up over there and check out
what's going on but podcast week will be
interesting and I do want to devote more
time to that you know what we're doing
here on YouTube this is long form in a
lot of respects this is radio I come
from radio I had a show on Sirius XM so
I would like to invest a little more in
podcast so I will think about that for
sure Dave if you ever get a chance
please check out ranting monkey this is
super chet he works hard at what he does
and I think he's worth worth listening
to okay I I don't know who ranting
monkey is but it sounds like someone
that has a monkey avatar on Twitter and
I will take a look at the ranting monkey
let's see
from super chat some guests on daily
wire podcast a few days ago said us is
now falling slowly like the once
powerful Empire of Rome culturally and
politically your thoughts you know I
look I think about this stuff I really
do I mean I I this is what I do for my
life so I worry about what's happening
in Western society about whether our our
successes have led us to a place where
we're let it we're just giving it up
we're we're young people think that
socialism is cool that this leftist
nonsense is cool that the oppression
Olympics is cool but suddenly
segregating based on race is cool that
the ideas of Martin Luther King and JFK
that were true liberals liberals that I
believe in that these ideas are becoming
old-school Martin Luther King and JFK
would most likely be conservatives by
today's standards so I don't know that
it's so specifically exactly like this
the fall of Rome but there is something
to that that there is a civilization
battle right now look what happened in
London the other day every week this is
happening something is happening
somewhere every week if not every day we
don't even talk about all them because
you know sometimes two people get killed
in a stabbing we just don't talk about
it the West is going to have to decide
how to deal with this and free loving
people and pluralistic democracies are
going to have to figure out how to deal
with this and if we don't well yes
civilization will crumble but there's
also a risk that if we don't that some
really bad people in our own country
right now will grab power and do things
that are horrible so that's why I've
tried to fight for liberalism because I
think it is the best answer to this
stuff but we have our we have major work
cut out for us I mean there aren't many
politicians that I think are very good
our our system is screwy but by by the
way again watch my interview with Jason
tomorrow don't get totally caught up in
just the Twitter world and the online
world in the comment world because the
real world is not totally connected to
that and there's a lot of goodness out
there too and it's hard sometimes you
forget that which is why I took the
weekend off off the grid so I didn't
tweet or even really check anything
about London until until Monday and in a
bizarre way
it was refreshing to not have to say
something about something I mean yes I
could have tweeted out my thoughts on it
and all that but you know everyone's in
on this feeding frenzy and I want to I
for my own sanity and spiritual Worth
and for you guys I I feel like I don't
want to add to the noise and I hope that
I hope you come here because I don't do
that you know there's so many questions
here we'll go a little longer than I
than I anticipated
let's see Dave this is from Facebook how
are you able to hear opposing views
without wanting to give correct or
alternative information um you know
unless someone lies to my face sitting
across from me and I know it so if they
fire off a bit of information or a stat
that I know is a factual lie then
usually people are just telling me their
opinion this is what I think about this
situation that's the purpose of an
interview so for the people that get
angry at me over you nodded at them when
they said this or you didn't push back
on that I picked my spots if you don't
like those spots I hope you're not being
forced to watch the show if you are I'd
like to find out who's forcing you to
watch I should probably talk to them
because I probably need more of them
but discerning truth is getting harder
and harder and I know all of you guys
are asking me this and guess what I'm
asking the same exact questions myself
going to get any comedians on the show
Jim Norton bill burr Colin Quinn would
be good ones I've reached out to Jim
I've reached out to bill my first ever
road gig when I was a stand-up my first
road gig was at the Mohegan Sun which is
outside of New York City couple hour
drive I drove bill burr up there he was
the headliner I was the opener I wonder
if he even remembers it but funny little
thing about that in New York City when
you're doing stand-up you're treated
like [ __ ] I mean you don't get paid or
they maybe give you a beer we have to
stand outside to hand out tickets so I
do this road gig at the Mohegan Sun I
was making a hundred fifty bucks which
after travel and everything else
probably lost money on it and I'm
opening for Bill bill Burke he wasn't a
big star at the time but he was like a
known comic in New York and I was I was
very excited and I remember right before
I get on stage couple hundred people
they're probably most people I ever
perform for uh the the manager of the
room of the club he goes mr. Rubin would
you like me to unscrew you the cap of
your water bottle before you get on
stage and I really thought I thought I
had made it like I really thought I was
like oh this is what making
you don't unscrew the cap of your water
a little did I know many years later of
doing stand-up and everything else that
was just one little brief respite of
nicety in the stand-up world but yes I
do want to do more with comics there's
plenty of people and I want to get Rogen
in here and a couple others so I'll
circle back on to a lot of those let's
see uh what is your opinion of Trump's
decision to leave the Paris agreement a
lot of people talk to me about this I
want to get somebody on who I think can
deal with this in an honest way look
there were a lot of hysterics over this
thing it was a non-binding agreement
that it sounds to me that a lot of the
burden was being put on the United
States there's a lot of complexity
related to this now again first off
beyond anything else I do believe in
climate science I am NOT a science if 97
scientist if 90% 7% of scientists say
something then I have to believe it I
can only accept I can only garner
information by people that are experts
in things that I'm not an expert in so I
do believe in climate change okay I've
had climate scientist on here and I'd
love to have more on here the question
about this the Paris agreement was is it
creating sort of artificial non-binding
regulations that some countries are
going to adhere to and some countries
aren't are countries like India and
China going to go through their
Industrial Revolution now and put a lot
of stuff out into the atmosphere while
we did it 50 years ago and it's so what
right do we have as the United States to
say you can't do now what we did then
now we know a lot more now but there's
an interesting conversation to be had
had there what disappointed me more than
anything about this was just the way
that people who never read the document
who know nothing about it
we're just screaming and everybody the
Earth's gonna end tomorrow the Earth's
gonna end tomorrow and it's like I I
hope that Trump is honestly having real
discussions about how we can change our
economy focus on more renewable clean
green energies and things of that nature
I have faith by the way that the private
sector and people like Elan musk who's
not happy with Trump over this will
start focusing more on that maybe if the
government seems to be completely inept
at doing this that that will spur more
private sector work in the green area so
I'm trying to be hopeful about it but I
do need to know more about it and we
shall see okay um
Facebook Dave answered my question and
I'll name my next cat after you what do
you make of the UK political scene is
May worth of vote these elections in
your opinion I'm very lost thank you
you're going to name your cat Dave after
this this is very except you know what
name your cat Clyde and I'll tell you
why in just a second Clyde is a great
name for a cat by the way or for a dog
or for a human
so on the UK front look I think Corbin
is a complete idiot and a regressive
leftist nut bag so that kind of leaves
you with may I guess some of her
response and the tweets to the two what
happened we're kind of crappy but I
think basically she's probably your
better choice it doesn't seem like we
have great choices right now politically
anywhere in the world it doesn't seem
like there's some really really great
choices but real quick on Clyde so I'm
so thrilled I mentioned this on the
patreon live feed that we did so most of
you guys know Clyde Drexler is my hero
of all heroes from my childhood
basketball player in the 80s and 90s he
was sort of the second best player after
Michael Jordan but played in Portland
and Houston smaller markets never got
the accolades he deserved but was a
great player played with grace and
dignity won a championship at a later
late stages career when people thought
it was over for him and anyway he's been
my hero my whole life and I've been
trying to get him on the show for years
I've reached out everywhere he doesn't
have a great social media presence blah
blah finally I asked my agent said
William Morris I was like can someone
get me contact with this guy my agent
sent me his number his phone number a
couple days ago I texted him we've been
texting I now have my hero's phone
number in my phone he's agreed to do the
show I don't know exactly when it's
going to happen but he does get to LA
often and we're going to do it
and it's like wow dreams actually do
come true very cool I don't even know
that he'll be the greatest interviewer
he's kind of soft-spoken not
particularly controversial but I think
for those of you that just dig what I do
I think you'll enjoy watching me kind of
fanboy out for an hour so that'll be fun
okay Dave you're super chat your
interviews are amazing and more
insightful than anything I've seen on TV
in my whole life what are your thoughts
on the abandonment of Israel from the
left curious to hear your thoughts so
next week we tape this already I have
Rabbi David Wolpe who's the rabbi at mat
Sinai temple here in Los Angeles we talk
a bit about Israel I've talked about it
with a bunch of guests here look Israel
is the one democracy in the Middle East
surrounded by a lot of undemocratic and
and often tyrannical States there are
people there from every walk of life
I've been there I've been to Tel Aviv
even in the last I was there I think
two-and-a-half years ago or so
where there were literally I saw a gay
couple holding hands in the middle of
the Middle East in the middle of the
street in the middle of day and nobody
cared there are there are Muslim women
in burkas and hijabs walking next to
ultra-orthodox Jewish men in the middle
of the summer with those crazy hats and
it's very hot I don't know exactly why
they're doing it I did ask the rabbi
about that but they're walking next to
each other on same buses in Jerusalem
the idea that there's apartheid there
it's the only place that allows for
freedom of religion and that allows for
minorities the third largest political
party in Israel is an Arab party they
have Arab Supreme Court justices that I
think the winner of their you know
American Idol the Israeli ATO ever was
an Arab they have Arabs that serve in
the in the military now all that said
are there problems absolutely are they
in equality problems absolutely but the
focus on this tiny little place that's
the size of New Jersey that without the
West Bank is about six miles wide I mean
think about that they have one airport
there one International Airport via the
endless focus on this place is by the
left is kind of ridiculous so look they
took every Jew Atta Gaza it made Gaza
worse they could take every Jew out of
the West Bank it would probably make the
West Bank worse and just bring more war
you could split Jerusalem Jerusalem is a
unified city now they're not to say
there aren't problems in Jerusalem but
again I was in Jerusalem you sit there
people I was there in the middle of the
stabbing spree and I walked through the
old gate through the Arab quarter it was
extremely tense but there are Israeli
soldiers walking by Arab men selling
kunafa and falafel and it's happening so
of course it's not perfect but the
unending focus on it on this one tiny
little place of a minority that of
people that have been hunted and hounded
and Holocaust it and programmed
throughout history does shows a real
issue with the left because the left
hates power so
the Jews were being slaughtered the left
would be all about the Jews now they
have some degree of power so the left is
sort of against them it's it's a it's a
sickness and a twist of the mind I
talked a bit about that with Dennis
Prager by the way um stroll ikaw there's
a lot here Dave your thoughts on sam
Harris's recent podcast guests Timothy
Snyder's warning that the far right and
our far left are right for being led
down a road to tyranny by an
authoritarian regime I haven't heard
that interview yet but I'm traveling a
lot over the next couple days and I have
a few podcasts I need to catch up on but
I absolutely believe that I mean the
I'll comment on the left thing because
that's a little more my specialty but
there's obviously this authoritarian
movement on the left this has been
primed to be grabbed by someone horrible
so if you think if you're against what's
happening with the left and you don't
like Bernie Sanders well guess what it's
going to get much worse than Bernie
Sanders one day old Bernie with three
houses and his hundred thousand dollar
car or whatever else he's got he made a
million bucks last year and everything
else none of which I begrudge him by the
way I believe if he earned it he can
keep it there the movement is going to
take him down one day too and though and
if you don't believe me watch that video
during the campaign when those black
lives matter activists grabbed the mic
from him and he just shut up and sat
there like a little [ __ ] basically
because this movement is about this this
is why this victimhood as virtue thing
is so dangerous it's going to eat itself
now for someone that doesn't like this I
don't mind them eating themselves but I
think it could be grabbed by a much
harder authoritarian regime or leader
and that would be terrible
by the way just quickly on the right of
course that could happen to the further
off whatever the far parts of the right
are right now and I'm not talking about
Pepe and Harambee and kekaa Stan and the
[ __ ] posters okay who are having fun Jib
by wrangling feathers or ruffling
feathers wrangling chains but whatever
that element of the far-right that
actually is a nationalist far-right
based in some sort of ethno nationalist
something or other that doesn't want
america to be the place that is for all
people that it is enshrined in our
Declaration of Independence and our
Constitution this is a problem
absolutely this problem that doesn't
have institutional power the
left stuff right now his institutional
power at colleges and television and all
asset and that's why I think it's bigger
problem at the moment um hey Dave I'm a
huge fan do you've any good book
suggestions so I was thinking of maybe
doing like a book club thing or
something which I know it's sort of
corny but I think it would be fun if
like once a month we all picked a book
then we do a live stream about it maybe
I Skype in some of you guys
I can either maybe get an author on or
something like that so I've been
discussing that with team I would say on
Liberty by John Stuart Mill is probably
the most politically influential book
there is for me and it's not that hard
to read very quick and another one that
really influenced me a ton is I've read
all Carl Sagan's books I've got one of
them right here but his last book was
called billions and billions he actually
died before it finished so his wife and
Riaan had to finish it but it's a great
summation on his thoughts of the world
on just so much deep rich stuff I'm due
for a read reading of it myself but I
would say those are the two that would
be good um let's see this is from
Facebook how's the West Hollywood LGBT
community treating you based on your
political beliefs well I moved from West
Hollywood so I'm not there that often
but yes the the I mean people have asked
me this you know the gay community has
been in lockstep with all this leftist
stuff I see a huge shift right now I may
I discuss this a little bit with ayaan
that's some minority communities so the
black I think the three in particular
right now the black community the Jewish
community and the gay community are also
having major splits where for the first
time there are voices in those
communities talking about liberalism in
what I mean by that is individualism and
talking about some libertarian stuff and
getting away from this collectivist
stuff because they see the dangers of
why they're being thrown under the bus
in in on they're being thrown under the
bus basically by ideologies that want to
keep them oppressed and none of these
people should be oppressed nobody should
be oppressed so usually when I walk
around West Hollywood people would say
nice things to me because generally if
someone's going to say hi to you they're
going to say something nice well I've
had a couple instances where people have
come up to me and said something not too
pleasant but that's alright that's what
okay let's see
super chat as a fellow gay man how do I
argue with leftists that proclaim to
represent me while at the same time
hating me for being white and a trump
voter so this is sort of what I'm
addressing in the one before that it's
tough right it's it's a tough situation
because you know gay thought Milo and I
talked about this a bit gays used to be
subversive and edgy and funny and drag
queens which I never liked drag queens
and I always thought a lot of gay comedy
was horrible and a lot of their the TV
shows were bad and all that stuff
I was never into that whole scene but
being gay used to be about being the
other making fun of everything mocking
everything fighting the power now gay is
so entwined in what the leftist ideology
that is the dominant ideology in this
country that gays have now become in
many respects the most politically
correct and in a certain way the most
intolerant so I see this now I get a ton
of email from gay people saying the
exact thing that you're saying here well
I'm either now a libertarian or I'm a
conservative or I care about taxes or
I'm a Trump supporter and I'm being
kicked out of the gay group think I
think you just got to be brave like
anybody else you know I mean I I'm just
one person telling you what I'm thinking
but you will find better friends it goes
back to where we started with the lacy
thing if your friends aren't happy with
you and they don't like the way you're
thinking well at some point not that you
should be giving up friends over
politics because I don't believe in that
but if people are giving up on you
sometimes you have no choice so you know
that one's tough what is your favorite
meal that David self described as your
personal chef cooks which of his recipes
would you most recommend so for those of
you that don't know David my husband
he's the producer of the show here but
his real passion is cooking you can go
to instagram.com slash David's cookbook
he's an incredible incredible chef and
over the last couple weeks we've had a
ton of family here from his brother and
sister-in-law and his sister and my
sister and my brother-in-law my niece
and his dad and my parents are come in a
couple weeks been running a little air
B&B over here so we've been eating some
amazing stuff he makes an incredible
chicken parm in a cast
and that's probably my favorite thing
but he roasts all kind of whole chickens
he'll do filet mignon and he does this
incredible Japanese beef stew
instagram.com / David's cookbook and and
he's working on a cookbook by the way so
stay tuned for that um let's see a whole
bunch about the gay thing for Trump
supporters which i think is interesting
any advice for a gay centrist Trump
voter looking for good ways to debate
leftists who few who refuse to
acknowledge Islam's role in terrorism in
England again I mean I think have it
honest conversation as you possibly can
do you think if these ideas if the ideas
of the Islamists are imported here if
these ideas take root here look where
the ideas are now is this good for gay
people so if if you don't think the
ideas are good for gay people where
they've already taken root would they be
good here now that doesn't mean you
should start prejudging and being
prejudiced to someone who happens to be
Muslim who you don't know how they
practice their faith who may just want
to live like you want to live and have a
job and have some sex and play video
games and and you know shoot hoops but
that doesn't mean you shouldn't be
allowed to talk about the ideas that's
the difference between ideas and people
and we should always fight against bet
if there was an anti gay political party
or nante woman political party or a
political party that said women are
gonna have to wear burqas we may throw
gays off roofs we're not going to be
tolerant of religious minorities or any
of those things and that was a political
party you the left would be up in arms
they'd be saying you're evil Republicans
and conservatives but when these ideas
come out of religion we suddenly get all
offended and this is just this is silly
lazy thinking that we have to destroy a
super chat hey Dave I'm a big fan of
show I'm a writer with Odyssey online
and want to address the growth of
radical Islam in Europe but I'm worried
about pushback from my sjw's tips on how
to combat it I mean everyone asked me
this you can see it's been a sort of
theme here lately um I don't know what
you can do other than slowly maybe start
showing people clips of conversations
that we've had around here some of the
conversations that ion has had watch
some old Christopher Hitchens stuff
watch some George Carlin stuff when he
wasn't necessarily dealing with Islam
specifically but was dealing with
ideas get people to open up and and and
try to try not to be as outraged as they
are so when you get into a heated battle
try to have them take a step back I
think that's the best thing you can do
but it is not going to be easy and the
more you talk about this up as Lacey's
going through as I've gone through as
many of you were going through yeah some
of you will lose some friends and things
like that it's it's just unfortunate but
it is how it is are you going to have
red pilled lacy green on and have you
seen her nude I have not seen her nude
but uh we she is going to come on yes
what's your thoughts on Milo's new book
deal
so I does he have a new deal since the
the Simon & Schuster thing went down or
is he self-publishing I'm not sure but I
suspect he's probably going to sell way
more books now because they made a
martyr out of him which if they would
have just ignored him that would have
been the biggest thing he would have
feared and he probably would have gone
away and I'm sure we'll have Milo back
at some point patreon when will America
get a new centrist political party with
the brain can you help start it and as
it stands both parties are broken have
you ever spoken with anyone from the
Manhattan Institute
I haven't spoken with anyone for the
Manhattan Institute I do think a
centrist party is possible as I said
before I think the Libertarian Party is
ripe for hijacking they're on the
they're on the ballots already they've
done nothing down ballot which is a [ __ ]
you know they only run for for president
they never do anything down ballot I
think they should start doing some stuff
down ballot I think if some sensible
people guy like ben shapiro let's say
said you know what i'm running under the
libertarian ticket he could probably
suck half off the republicans
immediately and take some from the from
the same democrat i have some issues
with that but i think that would be that
would be kind of interesting um i my
hope is that as this show grows as the
desire for some sanity and politics
grows which i think it will and it is uh
i hope that i I hope there's someone
running in 2020 that I can give a
full-throated endorsement to that I can
say this is someone who I think can make
things a little bit better but generally
speaking because my belief is things
would get better as we scale back
government that's not really the type of
people that run for government which is
why I like a lot of the ideas of Rand
Paul but when he was on the debate stage
it looked like he was he was uh you know
a clown
it was a clown show and he was
we're in any makeup which was which was
a problem for him uh much uh Dave would
you run as a libertarian for the 2028
presidential election I don't think I'm
gonna run the idea of going through that
monster that destructive beast where
they just want to destroy you and these
politics or not I think I'm good at the
idea thing I think I would love to
debate I'd love to be up there with the
debates and get my live skills and
stand-up skills and and because I have a
competency of understanding what I'm
talking about I would love to do all
that but the idea that they will just
destroy you they'll destroy your family
and all that stuff and by the way they
want you to know that so that no good
people run and that's why we only get
this certain class of people so I don't
think I would ever want to go through
that but I think that I will do
everything I can to always talk about
the ideas that I care about and
hopefully as I said hopefully there'll
be somebody there that I that I know
that I believe in um super chat can you
interview Terry a Davis on your show he
has some interesting stories about the
CIA someone emailed me about him today
I'm not sure who he is maybe it's you
that emailed but we will add him to the
list for sure um are you looking to
bring sam harris back on the show would
you talk about his views on trump russia
do you plan to talk trump with other
guests sam is always welcome back he
knows that the door is absolutely open I
owe him a tremendous amount of my
success and I and I admire him and I and
I love him as a friend so yes he's
welcome I'd be happy and yeah I'd be
happy you know we haven't done much
Trump stuff specifically on the show the
last couple weeks you know making a here
note here's what we'll do
I'll ask Scott Adams to come back Scott
is the creator of Dilbert who is a early
Trump supporter who I've had on who I
think is really big on that side I've
asked David from a couple times so I
know Sam is an admirer of who's hugely
anti Trump so I'll try to do you know
I'll try to do back-to-back shows maybe
we'll do two shows in a week one with
someone pro and one with some Andy and
then maybe we'll do one where I have two
people on together having a conversation
about it which by the way we're going to
do a little bit more of in about two
weeks we're doing our first real one of
those we have Dennis Prager on with
Michael Shermer both are former guests
and friends of mine Dennis did a video
for Prague
you on why you can't have morality
without God Michael did a counter video
I emailed them both and I said you guys
want to let's talk it out they both
agreed immediately so I'm excited about
that in this specific case I probably
agree with Michael Moore but I will do
my best to be a fair arbiter and I'm
certainly not scoring them at the end
and hand in a trophy to anyone I just
want to see people that are respectful
of each other talk and I'm pretty sure
Michael has even been on Dennis's show
before so this is by the way this is
where people with the difference of
opinion who both happen to lean right in
that dennis is a conservative and
Michael's a libertarian they're willing
to have that debate where I don't see as
much of that on the on the left what's
your favorite interior design style I've
noticed you have a bit of mid-century
modern pieces mixed in to your set so
first off for anything that you like on
is that I have to give a lot of the
credit here to Amira who designed it and
she did give me options on most of these
things so this is what we went so yeah
the chair obviously is mid-century
modern some of the I think the other
chair is probably mid-century modern I
do generally lean toward modern stuff
and kind of a clean look so my house in
general is kind of clean and by the way
I do listen to Jordan Peterson I like a
little bit of a mess in a house because
I feel like it makes me feel like I'm
live and there's a little bit of
spontaneity there David's very organized
and clean so we've come to a basically
happy medium on that but I generally I
do like the modern look but I also like
some sort of like industrial stuff and
some stuff to break it up a little bit
but I'm probably not the best interior
designer on the planet I don't think I
do have you know I said to Joe Rogan
once years ago that I'll know I'm
successful when I don't have all IKEA
well I don't have all IKEA anymore but I
still I still got plenty of Ikea they've
been around a while love watching you
answer the same question every time have
rational news youtubers thrown around
the idea of a political party you're
sort of asking me the same question so
you you do stand for what you uh what
you believe um
I there there's a lot of discussions in
this space that I can't fully talk about
but there's discussions about networks
there's discussions about parties about
how to unify all this stuff about how we
all won't be sort of bounty hunters in
this space you know I you know me and
Star Wars I always think this is like
Empire Strikes Back when Vader's talking
to two
AFET into bosque and the rest of them
you know bring me a solo and the Wookiee
but no disintegrations I feel like we're
in a little bit of that situation where
we're all kind of doing our own thing
and I would like to see a little more of
a unifying factor I think there's some
pieces in place for that and we shall
see you know I'm gonna do five more
minutes there's a zillion questions here
but I've got some other things to do and
we've been taping all day so um any
update on getting a lot musk or Neil
deGrasse Tyson on we've reached out to
both I actually saw bumped into a Neil
deGrasse Tyson in New York City about a
month and a half ago when I say bumped
into I sort of half stalked him I saw
him like on the corner you know wearing
his cowboy hat and whatever was right
outside of the museum a Natural History
and I kind of hunted him down
so I'm friends with Sam and I've had
lawrence krauss on the show and
bah-bah-bah I'd love for you to come on
and he said yes he has to reach out to
my people we did haven't heard back so I
hope we can get him and we shall see I
want that print Passat behind you who is
the artist I'm not sure which one you're
talking about if you're talking about
this one right here that's an original
that was done by Kahlan Janet her
website is Kailen cai CA y li n jan rose
CA y li n Rose Janet calm and she did
that one and she did the one above it
that you can't quite see right now this
print over here I'm blanking on who is
from I think it might add something to
do with NASA people ask me about that
one all the time
but by the way Kalyn Janet who's the Jet
Propulsion Laboratory is where is where
that print came from that print right
there
but by the way Kalyn Janet who's an
incredible artist she just painted we
commissioned her for a 5 foot by 6 foot
front view of the Millennium Falcon
Millennium Falcon as it's going into
hyperspace which I have in the room out
there and I have it on my Instagram I
think it's instagram.com slash Rubin
report and she's really doing some great
stuff so check her out and all right we
got three minutes left so if you're
jumping on super chat make it good
people hey Dave I'm a constitutional
conservative I'm a huge fan of your show
with everything going on in Europe do
you think there's any hope for
around or is it past the point of no
return uh I genuinely don't know I don't
think anyone knows I think that the more
that the west just turns its head or is
afraid to have an honest discussion
about what's going on or the more that
there are a terror attacks and the
immediate response is not about the
victims or the ideology that caused it
but about people that's that you're
saying have nothing to do with it well
we have to worry about Muslims now I
don't want there to be any crime towards
Muslims I want Muslims to be treated
equally I want everyone in society to be
treated ly but the more we move the ball
off what the real issues are and we
don't have leaders who will truly deal
with this honestly then you're going to
get demagogues and what does that mean
for the future of Europe you're either
going to have some sort of really
far-right nationalist populist thing
that will not be good Europe hat does
have a history of something like that or
you're going to have this this leftist
ideology in charge that refuses to deal
with the problem as the problem grows
and grows and grows so I don't know I
think Europe is changing massively and
we're just kind of sitting here and
watching it think about it if something
if something horrible happened in Paris
tomorrow we'd all be outraged again but
you wouldn't be surprised if something
happens horrible in London tomorrow you
wouldn't be surprised or Brussels
tomorrow and eventually if we don't have
that honest discussion you will start
being exported everywhere there are
obviously plans for it to be and we have
to start talking about honestly but I
don't know I do worry about that I
mentioned earlier like I genuinely worry
about and that's why I'm doing this what
is the future if we're not going to deal
with this then we're going to hand it to
people who are going to have much easier
answers all right people one more big
finish here um let's see uh there's a
lot of good ones here Shh
uh yeah I'll do two more quick ones so
one is about Colin Kaepernick's still
not receiving an NFL contract is he
being blackballed or genuinely not good
enough watch my chat with Jason Whitlock
tomorrow we really went into that and
he's been pretty outspoken about
Kaepernick and finally you know it's not
a question but it seems like the right
land and on Dave thanks for all your
hard work I stumbled on your show not
too long
ago and I appreciate the balanced
approach and great conversations well I
appreciate that and that's what I'm
trying to bring to you guys and you know
I'm not perfect but I do the best I can
and all right I think we got our test so
the whole point of this although I
always enjoy talking to you guys we were
testing out a couple things in our
simulcast to Facebook and YouTube it
sounds like it was a success always
happy to talk to you guys maybe we'll
start doing a little more of these live
Q&A through Skype right where I let some
of you guys Skype in and we can talk
directly to you that could be that could
be kind of interesting we shall see and
we got some other big plans as I
mentioned our podcast is monetized as of
today so for those of you that support
on patreon you you already do more than
enough for us and I thank you for those
of you that don't if you download our
podcast and you go to zip recruiter com
so that's Ruben that helps us out but
there are ads on there now it helps us
deal with the YouTube thing but we're
building a lot of great things I had a
great call with my agent today there's a
couple interesting things in place I'll
be doing the Greg Gutfeld show on Fox
News on June 16th I will be at oak on if
any of you were in Pittsburgh I'll be
there next week
talking with Steve Simpson and Fleming
Rosen a couple other people in your own
brook will be there who is mentioned
earlier and all right it's a little warm
in here right now so I'm going to wipe
my brow and say goodbye and Jason
Whitlock tomorrow thanks guys
you